from the promising action director of
the rock and bad boys comes his last fun
movie before transforming into the
Michael Bay we all know and age
Armageddon gear up for the best film
about drilling into an asteroid and
nuking it since the one that came out
two months earlier and let yourself
enjoy this guilty pleasure that's the
movie equivalent of Taco Bell looks okay
on the surface but for the love of God
don't think too hard about what's inside
prepare for an all-out assault on your
senses where everyone is always yelling
the clock is always ticking clock on
that nine-foot nuclear weapon is ticking
and everything that can go boom will go
boom
including the title of the movie
get ready for a Michael Bay version of
space where fiery explosions happen in a
vacuum
meteorites are filled with explosives
asteroids look like they were designed
by Tim Burton astronauts
only walk in straight lines Michael Bay
works at NASA space cars have guns
spaceships have guys where you do with a
gun in space space dementia exists and
is a big space dementia drunk Russians
can Fonzie a spaceship back to life
and it's easier to turn oil drillers
into astronauts then teach astronauts
how to use a drill I asked Michael why
it was easier to Train oil drillers to
become astronauts than it was to train
astronauts to become oil drillers and he
told me to shut the so that was the end
of that talk but this movie isn't just
about things exploding while guys make
loud noises of each other it's also
about love witness a romantic triangle
blossom between EJ Harry his Bruce
Willis ich die hardest mentor and
Harry's daughter grace who's just kind
of there to be hot she's a banshee is
fully hot if AJ wants to prove himself
worthy of Harry's daughter he'll have to
drill a deep hard hole right in the
crack of a big dark rock before Harry
will admit he's good enough at drilling
to drill his daughter don't take care of
my little girl found a job and if that
wasn't enough of a creepy
father/daughter relationship for you
watch as AJ seduces Liv Tyler while the
real dad sings for them in the
background doing this very same thing no
I can promise you they are not starring
taco-flavored kisses for my bed that guy
from all those movies
Bruce drill Asst man I'm glad I called
that guy data data dad looks like a lady
Wow Brad Pitt's Eskimo Pro notorious MCD
and b-roll drill hard sure they'll make
good astronauts they don't know jack
about drilling I mean this is a little
bit of a logic stretch let's face it
they don't know jack about drilling how
hard can it be
aim the drill at the ground and turn it
on be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers
Luke I am your father
gopher fall I'm gonna barf a hamster I
literally can't even right now there's
plenty of room in this town for the two
of us in a Michael Bay movie even the
title has to explode